and part-time jobs are topping
pre-pandemic numbers from 2019.
employers are struggling to fill them so
companies are turning to younger workers
elise preston is in las vegas with the
story
and even got to speak to my own son
about getting on the payroll
here we are 19 year old ethan bentz
earns his dough at the bagel cafe in las
vegas
now that school is out money is in i
expected to be you know an average first
job pay but that's
that's exceeded my expectations a little
bit ethan is part of a growing teenage
workforce
last month the share of 16 to 19 year
olds holding jobs
rose to more than 33 percent the highest
rate since 2008
ethan's boss is looking for more
employees just like him
anybody that walks in here like i asked
my customers
do you have a teenager son of a daughter
they want to work i have jobs
employers especially in leisure and
hospitality are struggling to fill jobs
wiped out during the pandemic but now
bouncing back full force jersey shore
hotel owner christina ronoro
increased the starting wage from 12
dollars an hour to 15 dollars an hour
we're really really short shorthanded
economists say hiring challenges
include parents struggling with child
care foreign students unable to get work
visas
and entry level seasonal work not paying
as well as unemployment benefits
there's still this expanded unemployment
benefit that's
you know keeping some workers from
coming back into the labor force filling
the jobs
where there are openings one of those
openings went to 16 year old sophia
shannon
it's my first job ever actually sophia
landed a job at a michael's store in
lexington kentucky and expects more of
her peers will punch in too
we all are like oh we're out of covet
and we're all old enough to work now
maybe we should do that teams across the
country
are finding a wealth of job
opportunities that could make this
a bankable summer in new york elise
preston 8 news now
look at ethan he's going for it i don't
know how much money is still left in the
bank i've got to check that
i have to say thanks to uh savas at
bagel cafe
ethan grew up coming here when when he
was a little kid
and he always got cookies at the counter
but
now he's serving those cookies and
coffees and bagels
and he's working hard i was i was at
bagel cafe
gosh maybe three weeks ago or something
like that and i saw him working
and i was gonna say hi but he was so
busy i felt bad
i didn't wanna i didn't want to get in
the way of ethan's uh focus
he was focused definitely i
want to give a big shout out to all the
customers at bagel cafe because
they're really loyal channel 8 viewers
so many folks always saying hi
so howdy to everybody this morning is
savas who is a super
super uh you know he's owned the bagel
cafe for 25 years wow
and is really he's got a loyal following
but it is tough
finding workers right now not businesses
all over las vegas oh yeah
top to bottom but it's easy to find a
great bagel at the bagel cafe
my favorite is the jalapeno with
jalapeno cream cheese
they have jalapeno cream cheese oh yeah
that sounds so good
it's easy to find ethan sherry because
he's eight feet tall
he does kind of tower over the tables